one of the phrases that's become
common parlance if you like since the
launch of pdf in the early 1990s is it's
okay i'll just send you a pdf
and a lot of people don't realize what a
broad church that is it covers a
multitude of sins yes you may get an
ultra high quality thing that could be
printed in vogue magazine in 23
different colors on glossy paper or
somebody may just say oh you all you
want is a copy of this of some sort i'll
just stick it in my scanner and send you
what amounts to a jpeg scan of the page
but since you've asked for pdf i'll use
the fact that pdf seems to be able to do
it but it doesn't upgrade it it just
sends you a bitmap scan only in pdf
format
what should we be saying
in addition to i'll just send you a pdf
to reassure people
that the quality will be there somehow
if you want
that quality to be
part and parcel of your story i'm going
to illustrate this in the end by just
showing you
an original bitmap pdf
of
dennis richard's thesis and when you
look at it the scan quality is very
variable but you think yeah typical jpeg
but it isn't its pdf so
it's a broad church you can have many
sorts of pdf so let's just run through
three
very important types of pdf
if you're a purist you may be thinking
well
a pdf of course has presumably been done
on a professional
piece of software like you know adobe
indesign so it'll be sharp and perfect
and everything
and if you have high expectations and
you want your pdfs to be infinitely
magnifiable up to barn door size and
have beautifully rendered colors well
then this aim in life i think adobe used
to call it pdf normal and my
ex grad student matt hardy still there
with adobe hello matt he said dave
people don't understand what pdf normal
means so i said well what do you call it
then he said oh well we use something
like pdf full text and graphics in other
words you've tried to choose the
features in pdf that enable you to
render that sort of material at the best
possible resolution if it's ftg you've
got to use proper fonts for characters
if you draw line diagrams you've got to
use something like adobe illustrator to
do them you must draw a line as a line
not as a set of dots you must draw a
circle as a circular curve not a set of
dots
and you resolve down to if you like
color to jpeg only for things that
really are like that photos scenery
people whatever that's absolutely fine
but if people are in a hurry or don't
have
all of this sophistication the other end
of the spectrum is you can basically use
um
a scanner to scan in a copy of your high
quality document rather than
regenerating it from source you might
say oh i can't be bothered i'll just
scan it
now if you just scan it in that's fine
it could be a good quality scan a bad
quality scan and just like with jpeg
tiff ping
all of these bitmap standards you may
have heard of and used for your
photography pdf
has its own
bitmap graphic capability that subsumes
all of those
so you could send somebody a pdf which
basically is little better than a jpeg
one of the things i'm finding in
fielding queries is that somehow and
it's great
pdf is a symbol of quality you know i
asked people to send me a pdf and all i
got was this lousy bitmap something like
that and the answer is yes pdf will
cheerfully render lousy stuff if you
give it that pdf i
for pdf image only you might think well
those are the two extremes then
everything thoroughly retypes it using
appropriate tools or at the opposite
extreme everything's a photo
everything's a jpeg everything's a
bitmap it's just we're calling it a pdf
bitmap and somebody at adobe said you
know could optical character recognition
ocr be of any help to us in the late 80s
early 90s adobe
bought a boston based
uh
graphics and ocr company whose name i've
now forgotten but it was an excellent
purchase because basically they said
if you have got high quality bitmap
scans
and you don't know what made them
we will have this wonderful thing called
acrobat capture
which will enable you interactively to
rebuild
to a very high standard
documents that were done in a
professional app that you don't have and
it was very good product the idea was
you had a room full of people
hundreds of them even you had a capture
server so you could share the task of
recreating a 10 000 document kennedy
library all brought back to life with
excellent precision it was too expensive
the number of libraries that will
rebuild in an entirety a whole
collection at super high quality is very
very limited but somebody somewhere i
don't know who it was but they deserve a
medal said ah but what this will be
ideal for
is
that in court judges
love having xeroxes and they've been
told not to call them xeroxes because
there are other photocopier companies so
they start
give me a photocopy and they love them
so what we want from pdf
is to retain
the roughness of the original but
somehow magically to ocr it
and make it at least
slightly searchable and somebody could
say to a yes your honor you're on page
three
the word
reprehensible will appear on line three
so just type in rep oh it's found it you
see
well
if you've got a page full of bitmap how
the heck do you find it the answer is
you have in some limited way to do ocr
on it to see if there's anything there
that corresponds to text
so the middle relay
was in many ways i think the saving of
pdf for large-scale commercial
applications this wonderful compromise
of saying we'll give you a bitmap
overlay
done with our technology but underneath
that
we will try our best but we won't go
completely mad maybe 70 to 80 okay from
a good scam we'll try and give you some
good searchability on this and not
totally perfect we're moving on now from
saying well
we can't do ftg image only is not good
enough quality we want more value
to the rescue comes pdf image plus
hidden text and the idea is
that you
recognize as much as you can you
recognize where on the page that phrase
is you have a guess at what the font is
using your best quick and dirty
technology and you say i can now make
this searchable insofar as my ocr makes
sense ask me for hello world as long as
i've recognized it i will highlight for
you back on the bitmap yeah
i won't just give you a listing saying
memorable phrases i discovered in this
bitmap i'll actually highlight them for
you because i know where they occur
that's a very long story short it was a
howling success it really was the idea
of having a bitmap that clearly hadn't
been messed with except it had
but which her honor could actually get
to see
the relevant phrase in context
highlighted on the bitmap was an
absolute winner you know in the legal
community let's go and find the
workstation where i'm currently trying
to rescue
dennis rich's thesis and to see what
versions of it i currently have
available
this office
this is my linux box running debian
linux so this is back to 1972's
software which i just happened to have
hung on to for projects of this nature
what you're seeing here
is
the end result of me rescuing this page
this is my pdf ftg i am using
exactly the right tools for properly
re-type setting a version of this
material
so you go there but this material is
mostly just rather complicated oh look
at that
hideously complex mathematical equations
you do not want to type that out
character by character by hand even if
you know what it means so what i can do
and it should scale up reasonably well
if i say here on the preview that i'd
like to
can you see i've asked it to be eight
times magnified
but look
the quality is still there
in fact i think i can go one more on
this preview software innately the
postscript pdf imaging model is capable
of scaling stuff up that has been
properly typeset it knows how to do it
now just for contrast let's take a look
at what the original
looked like now you can tell straight
away that's a photocopy
also
old-timers in there will immediately
seize on that and say that's a tally
tight print out and it is for some
reason dennis did the cover page
on a teletype but when you get to the
first real page as far as we know and
can tell that is what an ibm selectric
typewriter can do if you magnify this
not very good is it
look at that can you see it's all
breaking up i mean this is by no means
the worst page of course we say clearly
image only is not good enough for us
it's not searchable so
next people's exhibit number two then is
let's from here kill off that particular
pdf
richie dissertation ocr.pdf
let's see where we get to it looks the
same
and of course the
page bitmap overlays are the same but
sneakily and after several minutes of
processing it's hidden searchability
underneath
so let us now go on page one and let us
say at the wall we want to just find the
first the
in this document
oh it found one even earlier of course i
forgot that the default mode of this is
not case sensitive
it's founded there but with a capital t
what i've actually managed to do is to
get a searchable bitmap version of
dennis's thesis and that's absolutely
ideal to work from because i as a human
can read it and if i say
hmm
i'm sure we came across the word
submarine on this page i can try and
find it and i very likely will
so there you are then we've
you've
seen
totally reset material
which is
arbitrarily scalable and doesn't crack
up
this is clearly not a proper typeset
quality even at its native size here you
can see there's dots missing in the
typeface and and it's just not of that
crisp high quality
look that one so
searches after
when you're outputting a pdf you should
be
trying to output a pdf with full text
and graphics and treat everything the
way it deserves to be treated you should
not be taking shortcuts saying i don't
have enough fonts i'll just bitmap that
text the virtues of ftg not only include
quality but they include space
type setting text from within a font
takes a lot less space than reproducing
all the dotty bitmaps of your broken
letter t's and all this kind of stuff
equally
you don't want to subject your graphics
to being a photo with lots of white
pixels in there that have to be
compressed out and
causing grief all over no if it's a
straight line you just say line and that
gives you the appropriate command in pdf
to do a line you should aim for the
highest quality
that your audience or that the
application
demands and just be aware that there is
this
intermediate stage which i found very
useful is to look at a moderately okay
quality
bitmap as my guide to what i need to fix
and re-type but at the same time to be
able to find things inside it just about
we have to decide how much down sampling
we think we can get away with in general
it's very common to down sample the
color by a factor of two in both
directions so essentially you have four
times less colors
and they all end up in the neck or the
throat or whatever it's called and on a
conventional typewriter